so is that this one a concert the other
day oh yeah heard you say sergeant Tom
Agee's ouran host club band oh really
yeah um is that guy staring at us that's
really creepy I think it's just a
cardboard piece but who would put a
cardboard cutout facing out their office
window all night maybe it's just to
scare away burglars yeah I guess you're
right hmm right okay
thanks for watching being watched or I
guess I should say thank you for
watching the micro [ __ ] entitled being
watched because I could see how that
might be confusing if you haven't
already checked out Brice makes films
this is your last warning I mean click
over here and check it out because the
Internet is a free country so i know my
channel says monthly Horrors but i
figured since it's october and you
subscriber people are pretty cool by the
way there's over a thousand of you now
so thank you so much and just keep doing
that so i figured since it's october i
would just upload a whole bunch of
videos so on that note be sure to leave
what you're doing for halloween in the
comments and you'll be seeing more of me
very soon what